one thing's for sure this movie is going
to be a waste of time
nah what the hell john that was my
punchline
you were setting me up i was trying that
was my point if i'm doing the joke you
can't just come in there
let's just do this
[Music]
movie film which brought great shame to
kazakhstan
now i was instructed to return to yankee
land to carry out
secret missions
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh my real sexy peels
uh this is a bag that just goes over the
dress
i really like this sandra
jessica parker
here oh because i was the one who put
the baby in here
oh
then
[Music]
oh my god i said we didn't
really
just in time for the election obviously
oh goodness how funny thank you amazon
how funny my god
i have so many so many feelings where's
i think it looks really funny yeah it
looks surprising
and cringy looks very cringy looks pure
borat of course
it's probably not gonna have the same
shock value
as much as the first one did although i
gotta say that that convention moment
with mike pence there i'm surprised
we've never heard about that if like
that that looks
real yeah this i don't think this would
be the borat
film if it wasn't real at least try it
and i'm surprised we never heard about
someone
doing that at a convention yeah even if
they didn't know it was
sasha mary going you know yeah i feel
like we would have heard something some
kind of disruption involving
cameras into crew you'd think they would
heat pile on top of that as some kind of
attack of fake news or you know some
kind of attempt to sabotage
whatever maybe it was reported but we
just watched somehow didn't hear about
it
the republicans buried it that's what
happened or maybe the news is just so
absurd now that we heard about it
thought nothing of it and just went
right past
there's probably going to be a more
scripted bits
in here just because of the circumstance
of four ad is a lot more known now
although the the ones that are
definitely the highlights of this
trailer
are when they can't tell sasha baron
cohen like when they're at the toilet's
office
that looks so horrible it's such like an
uncomfortable scene
yeah yeah it's a special special kind of
comedy that he's able to zero in on is
like
horribly uncomfortable but also somehow
oddly revealing
and transfixing and also those rednecks
who uh
who who think they know how to destroy
the
virus they get sleepy they're sleeping
before they knock it out
get rid of the virus which stuff like
that really makes me wonder if those
people
you know offered their home up to him
for real or if there was some kind of
flexing or i know that like with the
earlier movies and with bruno they had
to do things where they would have these
contracts set up for like we're filming
a documentary and it's kind of what this
is but it's not quite what this
is but he looks like borat in in those
moments so like any of those i kind of
found myself
wondering as to what the full
authenticity might be because part of
the charm is that all the interactions
at least of those variety
are authentic the stuff that that made
me laugh i think too
was that i liked that they took
advantage of the fact that yes everyone
knows him now so just like
walking around the street and having
people recognize him and chasing him
around
like i'm glad that they at least took
advantage of that even though i'm
wondering about it it seems like they're
not shying away from it which
you know gives me hope for the movie's
experience i mean he's had that other
that showtime series going on which i've
only seen segments
of him having to work with even more
prosthetics and more makeup more
disguises
and specifically generally going after
the republican side he does do some bits
with like the democrats there's the
whole thing with bernie sanders and such
this seems like it's going to be more
a sasha bearing cohen movie and less of
a borat movie if that makes sense
yeah yeah him flexing his you know skill
for character
because he has to too although i don't
know actually he's
borat disguising himself as a different
person so how would it be
yeah it's still the borat voice
underneath a different makeup
you know or the black voice potentially
mixed with some other ungodly accent you
know hearing yeah that take on a
character trying to do another character
like it seems like it has yeah tons of
potential
that the whole thing with the daughter
though what was the plot of the first
one i know there was a plot
what was the plot he wanted to meet
pamela anderson or something merrier
well yeah it's like he comes to make a
documentary about america and then winds
up falling in love with pamela anderson
and he really wants to marry her
and then i think he just kind of has
like a mad cap adventure and
yeah loosely tied together and yeah this
seems like at least it's going with some
sort of i gotta make another documentary
and also marry off my daughter and the
father-daughter element seems like an
actual storyline to this movie yeah
whereas i think with the first borat
movie like how i just had to get a
refresher from john
i was i remember more of like a lot of
segments and a lot of bits but i was
like wait there's an actual plot there
and i just can't really recall what it
was
yeah and here it seems like they're
putting the plot kind of front and
center here with the daughter and father
bit
and it makes me wonder too about who
they got to play the daughter because it
seems like you would need somebody who
is just as
sort of insane and fearless as sasha
baron cohen someone who looks like isla
fisher
yeah yeah i thought it was her when we
were first looking at her yeah
yeah and you know somebody who's gonna
yeah be in these improv situations with
real people that could go any direction
like it's
i'm curious as to who she is and how
they found her because it seems like you
would really need somebody who can
absolutely hang with whatever madness
sasha baron cohen's doing because he
gets deep deep into character for these
from what i understand
so what's the actual title the borat
subsequent movie film delivery
of prodigious bridesmaids
not are you sure it's not predicts
prodigious prodigious bribe
to american regime for make benefit
once glorious nation of kazakhstan to
give its full title
wow you know it's been many years and i
still don't even remember the first time
you don't remember cultural learnings of
america for make benefit glorious
never you nailed that that's what i
learned in high school
oh god i was wondering if they would i'm
surprised
too that they actually are still keeping
kazakhstan even though it's such an
ingrained it's it's
part of the character's identity but
that caused such problems when the movie
the first one came out because you know
that's an actual place
sasha baron cohen doesn't care he's
always on the verge of a major lawsuit
that will destroy his life that's his
status quo
all right guys we're bored too did you
like the trailer are you excited for it
do you think it looks funny do you think
it'll be as good as the first leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell it's october we'll be
covering
a lot of stuff this month and last but
not least
katie anne i wanted to give you a shout
out today because after all
the great writing you have done for
through the lookinglast.water.blog
you have been putting out great reviews
over there and i love your personality
i've been wanting you to go on camera
for such a long time and the fact that
you finally started up a stardust
account
and you've been posting regularly all
things considered
i think that is a great first step and i
think you're doing an excellent job you
will be an
ultimate star duster in no time and then
you'll be on here reviewing movies
instead of us
exactly so katie thank you for being you
thank you for the
overwhelming amount of support uh like
there's so many things to thank you for
but uh right now i just want to focus on
how proud i am of you for taking
that uncomfortable step because you are
doing a great job
keep stepping out of your comfort zone
[Music]